troubling story that developed in recent
days involving now
former seahawks tackle chad wheeler
he was jailed over the weekend on
charges of suspicion of domestic
violence the details are shocking you
can find them online we've got
links to the stories at pft the seahawks
after i think just hoping they could let
nature take its course he was going to
be a restricted free agent you just
don't tender him you let him go
it never comes up again they eventually
had to act they issued this statement
which i think was appropriate and uh it
was it was a day
of a lot of people wondering why the
seahawks weren't saying anything why the
nfl wasn't saying anything the nfl told
me they were reviewing the matter under
the personal conduct policy
but the details were so shocking that it
cried out for something
more immediate and there were other
players current
former players that that were basically
saying that this is not acceptable to
mario davis everyone that represents the
nfl should speak
out against this and also benjamin
watson said let this be a wake-up call
and the nfl had its wake-up call with
ray rice
i i just i i think that when we see guys
like ezekiel elliott
get suspended for six games and i know
it took time for it to happen didn't
happen immediately but he was never even
arrested
when you have an arrest when you have
credible allegations
when you have a guy who's placed on four
hundred thousand dollars bail
that is a more serious matter for the
nfl and again
i think from a pr standpoint my guess is
nobody wanted to bring more attention to
it and thought
it'll just kind of fizzle out they
eventually had to act
because it clearly chris was not going
to fizzle out and it shouldn't have
fizzled out no no that's not the type of
story that is going to fizzle out you're
right i mean
the seahawks they got to the bottom and
got it you know done the right way but
that's scary i mean it's a scary
incident we know that
um that could have been you know it
sounds like it was teetering very close
to being a very
dangerous bad look for the league in
general and those
type of things and you know i give guys
like demario davis benjamin watson a lot
of credit for kind of getting out there
and
and yeah just putting their name to it
and going like not acceptable
we're not going to stand for this and uh
of course we shouldn't
we hear all the time that playing in the
nfl is a privilege not a right and if
that's the case that privilege needs to
be revoked immediately when something
like this happens and
you know the sad reality is
if this had happened to a star player
there would be a second chance
for chad wheeler there won't be a second
chance because he's not good enough
if he was good enough someone at some
point
somewhere would talk about how as a
society we embrace second chances and
he's made amends and
yeah you know and and it's at the
expense of someone else's first chance
who's never done anything wrong
because there's only 53 spots on a
roster but we know how that works in
sports that's not an indictment only of
the nfl i don't know this one though
it's at all levels
but if you're good enough the passage of
time and if you make amends
you check all the right boxes you're
going to get a second chance if you're
good enough if you're not
bye-bye if you if you are they'll find a
way to do it i mean my god mike vick was
back in the nfl two months after he got
out of prison
i i understand i i you know but i don't
think in a lot of people's eyes that
like is is is egregious and crazy
sometimes is the thought of this giant
man having choked
some woman or you know allegedly and
dealing those things and you know you
see some of the other horror stories
that were out there around it
and things like that you know this one
is one where
i don't know i don't know if i could say
that oh if he was a lot better
he'd get a free pass with this one i i
don't know when you when you start
talking about
some of the things we hear allegedly and
things like that
i think teams would be a little scared
certainly like
like the ray rice situation let me just
say this before we take our break and
i'm not going to name names here but
there's a guy who's getting ready to
play in the super bowl
who was involved in a very egregious set
of facts and
pleaded guilty to certain crimes years
ago
and if he wasn't as fast as he is he
never would have been in the nfl
so your talent secures you a second
chance when the facts that you were
involved in otherwise would disqualify
you
permanently if you are good enough you
will get your second chance
and and sometimes make the most of it
and
end up in the super bowl as one of the
best players on one of the two teams
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports